[Music]
well Wolfgang
it's been a few days but Marvel has
given us another new trailer with some
new footage in it that's the whole story
yes
war machine story oh this is very good
then in this video we'll talk about some
of the new scenes that we see and what
they could possibly mean but before we
get started no one will know if you
press that little red subscribe button
just you and me do it nobody would know
nobody
now that's nice no I'm an old trauma
sitting on them oh yeah I'll be missed
also if you're a fan of the videos that
we make here and would like to support
us please consider visiting our patreon
page
anything is appreciated and you can find
the link below alright check out this
new trailer
and run from it
the end is near we're gonna need some
help
how you been buck not bad for the end of
the world
[Music]
[Music]
David don't fight for one
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war when you said we
were going to open what conduct to the
rest of the world this is not what I
imagined or give you imagine the
Olympics maybe even a Starbucks
everywhere April 27
okay first new scene that we have here
low-key with Proxima midnight spear
pointed at his head what we already know
about this scene is is that Loki will
most likely betray Thanos judging by the
look on his face it looks like he's come
to a decision
Dana's just wiped out all if not most of
what's left of his home planet Asgard
this is most likely his last attempt to
try to save what's left of Asgard and
his brother Thor if you like to know
more about this scene you can check out
a video I did about it in a link above
the next news thing we have is Tony
Stark telling Wong and Doctor Strange
Bruce Banner most likely we're gonna
need some help what's most likely
happening here is that the Hulk just
crashed through the sanctum sanctorum
and then turned into Bruce Banner and
then Bruce Banner warns them that Thanos
is coming I believe that the Hulk just
witnessed a nose destroy most of what is
left of Asgard and even tried to fight
Thanos himself so he is stressed seeing
how powerful tannaz is to Tony this is
probably what makes Tony say we're gonna
need some help we've heard Tony say this
and other trailers but now we have the
visual to go along with it this next
scene is really awesome we see Captain
America and Bucky see each other for the
first time since civil war captain Pat's
him on the shoulder and asked him how
he's been in which Bucky replies not bad
for the end of the world
Bucky jokingly saying it's the end of
the world implies that everybody truly
knows how strong vanishes in this next
scene we see King T'Challa or the Black
Panther standing in front of all
wakandan tribes he then starts a War
Chant which is appropriate seeing as how
they're all about to go against
Stannis's army but I don't know what
they're saying because I don't speak
with Condon can anybody help me out let
me know in the comments below thanks
this next scene is awesome we have fan
OHS arriving in Wakanda this is awesome
because we've seen thinness in Wakanda
already where Steve manages to resist
him with the Infinity Gauntlet somehow
but this scene looks like it's when
Thanos first appears in Wakanda probably
after laying a serious whooping down on
the Avengers who are on Titan
the next scene is Falcon and Bucky or
the white wolf and they seem to be
looking up at something which I'm going
to assume as Stannis's ships arriving on
what Conda for the first time the next
new scene is very brief but it is of
black widow it looks like her and some
of the wakandans just got done fighting
in which then a new wave of soldiers
from Thanos his army comes out and then
she gives a kind of uh well alright type
of look the next day of scene is also
very brief but it is of Shuri it looks
like she's in Wakanda and she's using
one of her new weapons that she's made
but since she's in Wakanda the question
is is she showing this to somebody or is
she using it on an enemy looks like
we'll find out in 20 days next you've
seen awesome Thanos the mad Titan
jumping to attack somebody but if you
look closely it actually looks like he's
breaking out of something if you can
look at this orange lava type thing it
looks like this was surrounding Thanos
and if you look at the top of it it
looks like he's busting out of it you
can see the rocks are actually going
away from him making it seem like he's
jumping out of it and then they're going
away also these orange wave laser beam
type things look like something that dr.
strange could come up with so maybe this
whole thing was dr. strange trying to
trap Thanos whatever it was it obviously
did not hold danos back in the slightest
and someone's about to get punched in
the face
this next new scene is actually my
favorite in this trailer it's of Scarlet
Witch you can see Scarlet Witch Natasha
Rove enough for Black Widow and to cool
you in the back and it looks like
they're surrounded by thanasis Army in
which Scarlet Witch just comes out and
is about to launch a massive attack
which I'm sure will wipe them all out
interestingly enough vision is nowhere
to be found in these scenes as he
perhaps already met his doom and Thanos
has already gotten the mind stone from
him or is he just simply not shown the
last scene in this new trailer is
obviously put in there for humor
purposes and it's probably much needed
comic relief due to the fact that dannis
is probably gonna whip everybody and
kill some people are wrapped in America
and it's gonna be much needed laughter
well that is it for all the new scenes
in the new trailer that Marvel was so
generous to give us today I'm sure
Marvel will be giving us another one
pretty soon and when they do I'll be
sure to let you know as always leave
your comments below like this video and
be sure
to join the wolfgang by hitting that
good old looking subscribe button right
there thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]